بعد وصول رائدي الفضاء السعوديين علي
القرني وريانه برناوي لمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه بدات مهمتهما العلميه ودارت في
اذهان متابعي الحدث التاريخي اسئله عديده
فقمنا نحن في قناه العربيه بالبحث عن
الاجابات التاليه علي وريان يحملان على
عاتقهما اربع عشره تجربه علميه بمعدل
تجربتين يوميا في بيئه خاصه منها تجارب
بعينات جاهزه مثل اي نوع من انواع
الالتهابات وهناك تجارب تتطرق لصحه
الانسان في الفضاء كالتاقلم مع البيئه او
قياس العلامات الحيويه مثل قياس قطر عصب
العين واخرى مثل عمليات الاستمطار وقياس
تاثيرها وانعكاساتها البيئيه اسئله اخرى
شغلتكم وشغلنا البحث عن اجابتها كيف يتغذى
رائد الفضاء السعوديان خارج الكره الارضيه
مشاهدينا كمال سكان الارض حميات غذائيه
محدده لزوار الفضاء ايضا حميه خاصه
من ثلاث وجبات يوميا محضره باشتراطات ناسا
كيف ينام رواد الفضاء مع انعدام الجاذبيه
واختلاف التوقيت الزمني والبيئه يبدا يوم
رواد الفضاء الساعه الثامنه صباحا وحتى
الساعه السادسه مساء تتخلله اوقات للانشطه
بعدها يحين وقت الراحه داخل حقيبه نوم
خاصه مثبته ماذا عن التواصل مع سكان الارض
الاهل والاصدقاء نعم مسموح لرواد الفضاء
بالتواصل مع من يريدون لكن عبر الاتصال
الصوتي فقط اما المرئي فيخصص للفريق الطبي
واخيرا نطمئن مشاهدينا بان جميع من على
محطه الفضاء مدربون على الاسعافات الاوليه
للتعامل مع اي حالات طارئه لا قدر الله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات